lisa foiles with gamespot here with jude
one of a lead artist the lead artist the
lead artist here on alien isolation now
tell me a little tell me a little bit
about this game I know it's I know it's
scary ok so we've we try to take the the
franchise back to its roots here really
this is about one on one survival how
how will how women can splay out between
a human being and a 9-foot terrifying
monster it's not it's not about guns
blazing and a kind of an approach it's
we just want to take take the thing back
to its roots really and see just how how
you would survive are you guys big fans
of the movies before you you know sorry
we're going to seem like how many times
have you had to go back and watch the
original movie before you mate so the
original movie we love it I think that
all the ascetics we've taken we taken
all of our cues from the original movie
the 1979 classic and you know before we
start at the game I thought it was a
beautiful beautiful film that having
I've been worked on the game now for
nearly three years I couldn't tell you
how many times I've seen it hundreds if
not thousands of times and the more you
see it the more there is it's an amazing
piece of cinema and just a you know a
seam of gold that just keeps on going
absolutely love it if they want to talk
to you about arts because I feel like
you would know something about that so
you're you know you're kind of
recreating these characters you know
from the movie like you have to take
something they made in the movie and put
it into the game did you have did you
struggle with you know trans
transferring that onto paper and also I
assume you created new characters like
new enemies okay yes sir the original
alien is obviously it's almost a
household name everyone knows they knows
what it looks like or at least they
think they know what it looks like but I
mean going back to all the archive
materials from Fox and you know really
taking this stuff apart we've as I say
we just you know you think you know what
it looks like but you don't until you go
deep and the details it is amazing yeah
I mean recreating or yes we have
recreated things from the original movie
but I think more importantly than that
we've kind of expanded on that universe
we've kind of deconstructed everything
understood how it was put together and
then
able to you know rebuild an environment
which you know feels like it could have
been on the set of 1979 so you're
talking about how it's not a guns
blazing experience I mean you're not
just trying to obliterate as many aliens
as you can is it more of an emotional
experience I think it is it's all about
atmosphere an immersion and I mean again
going back to the alien there you know
we've created a really high fidelity
believable enemy and because it is so
believable you know you feel like you
are in the same space as this terrifying
creature and yeah I mean it plays on
your emotion I mean you'll pray out
there right that this thing is going to
kill you if not worse when it finds you
and yeah it's it definitely plays on
icon if I think you know probably more
fears you tell us real quick the
storyline and how the story of your game
connects to the movies ok so our story
takes place 15 years after the original
movie and it stars Amanda who is a Ellen
Ripley's daughter and basically the
story starts with the discovery of the
Nostromo black box or flight box and a
small crew go out to you know recover
this box and among the volunteers for
the mission wants to know what's
happened to your mother she wants to
know the truth behind behind you know
the mystery or whatever and so um yeah
that's how it starts alright well I
thank you so much for talking to me
about it I any for any final words any
tidbits that the fans at home don't know
about alien um about ok so here III
today we've got a little prototype demo
over on on the oculus rift Stan please
go and check that out it is unbelievable
we well thank you so much alright see
you guys later